hello everybody and welcome to part 3 of
let's play la caza all right got my
hammer gonna smash this rock or lock not
Rock unfinished chambers this sounds
safe
the intense feeling of being watched
returned as I entered the corridor the
smell of rotting flesh was present oh
that means nothing to me
bring it on what do we got here uh-huh
not scary not scary
hello is there a monster here nope
nothing nothing nothing at all
okay those useless room whatever moving
on what do we get
what have we got Oh spiral staircase
scary
[Music]
all right there we go okay I'm up here
moving this the way for no reason all
right
oh well that seems safe oh oh maybe if I
put a rock down there okay I got it
and this comes out to the other room
then okay boom oh yeah
got you [ __ ] yeah oh yeah who's the
best all right
making so much progress
oh yeah ah all right okay yeah it's
nothing Oh bring it on oh man I'm like
put into a false sense of security by
penumbra Requiem just charging around
every corner okay all right what did I
get
okay got chipper hammer chipper okay
there we go okay oh oh no oh no no no no
no Oh get out here go get out of here
huh how did it how does it get out there
okay all right I doesn't matter I can
make it exits right there all the exits
right there
what's going on what's going on what's
happened something collapsed monster
yeah yeah you're nowhere
you're nowhere
the temple is alive something is nearing
me something I could hear and feel but
not see the darkness may be very okay
finally it's like that would take a long
time to do with just the chipper and a
camera oh but I'm so strong Oh ripped
apart like it was nothing oh that was
all those back here to the valve okay
alright that did something right
whoa stop moving on you all right um
okay like a water pipe so maybe maybe if
I go back to the water works down in
that basement area that makes the most
sense I guess and they do not like given
me much lantern oil all right but
whatever I don't need it oh but what but
but ah all right
well
can't go on the waterworks I turn this
giant pipe see oh well all right then I
guess I can only go one way now come
with me you need to have a talk
what's going on around here oh this door
[ __ ] you Oh get out here get out here
Gary here Oh what huh
I'll get a chair fall back off a hole
back off back off okay okay okay
okay I don't know what that was all
about
it was like chasing the end but it just
gave up Hawke of it saw I had my chair
it was all like oh oh I'm getting out of
here
oh he looks so tough and manly and
handsome I'm not messing with him yeah
oh god he's still there isn't it oh okay
go go go go go skull you betrayed me get
here oh okay all right
oh this is a dead end oh there's dinner
oh this looks breakable No
oh boy always coming back in thee always
coming back okay he's got a do and I'm
came here to do I don't know what that
is but I came ready to do it huh okay
all right I need a lantern or something
or I need a torch maybe I don't know
what was the point of that huh okay all
right okay um I don't know I don't know
huh I think that was it wasn't anything
in that run okay that monsters gone no
notes I bet I'm willing to bet that I
can't go the way I came
what the oh yes I can
that thing is hunting me I could hear
running water at the main chamber oh
okay
Alyssa posed to come here all right here
we go oh man whoo boy what we leave to
the pit okay okay hi huh huh I heard a
voice is have I had been the sound of
roaring water and gold me hours passed
and once again I woke up somewhere I'd
never been okay okay uh
okay all right I'm okay sorry if I
overloaded the mic there it was good
okay Wow Wow okay Wow okay all right did
not expect that
huh okay all right I'm okay okay okay
okay man no wonder this is hook good I
could take it explodes no wonder this
was top rated and custom story is good
oh that is scary
oh man leaving that open cuz I know I'm
gonna need it oh man huh it's come to
our attention dangerous to our health
stay those in the where harmful spores
chemical a in use with chemical B
extract cyanide
ah okay
alright I'm okay guys I'm okay I'm okay
knows nothing that was nothing huh lab
was somewhere I almost felt at ease too
bad it wasn't my lab though yeah do that
alright Oh music got a little more tense
but I am tough so bring it on
we got here cave-in anything huh okay
alright okay okay coop right I know coop
right
I remember cooperate cooperate is a
crystalline form of copper or something
I learned that the first let's play I
ever did okay leaving I got all these
chairs and a closet to hide cowardice oh
boy oh why didn't that fill up halfway
third of a volatile mix okay lots of
chairs okay I like it I like it
lots of chairs okay okay
Oh who's there nobody okay oh no even
raw he's running out tinderboxes huh
what that huh what uh
what was the point of that skull are you
trying to tell me something what the
where mylanta go why can't I use my
lantern what oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] me oh no no no no no no no no
no no no no where am i where am i oh
where am i where am i where am i where
am i where am i where am i oh no oh no
no no no please okay I can't go anywhere
I can't go anywhere I went in a big
circle okay I'm okay I'm okay okay I'm
okay why am I going in a circle why we
go in a circle wait how am I going we're
going tell me talk to me what's going on
what's happening okay all right fun game
what what's going on uh-huh okay okay
I'm back okay and I'm okay you can see I
can use my lantern again okay all right
ha oh this is getting freaky all right I
gotta cut it here guys wow wow wow wow
wow oh man he's so glad to be getting
back into the scares or at least I hope
you're all glad uh okay all right thank
you guys so much for watching and I will
see you guys in part 4 of let's play
lacasa bye bye